we only have 24 hours to bring the rest
of him back hey dad you look just like I
remember congratulations
I think Tsar has made us cry over so
many different things
monsters fish toys how is Pixar gonna
make us cry over a pair of pants this
time well that's a great question
the pair of pants is not so much just a
pair of pants but it's what the pair of
pants isn't and I think what's lacking
in that pair of pants is a relationship
between these two boys and their father
and so as these boys go on this journey
and this magic filled quest in this
world of magic and fantasy they are able
to you know uncover magic in the world
and the magic of the relationships
between one another as they both so long
to get to know the dad that they lost I
think it all just goes to even when
things are fish or monsters it's all
still human emotion it's all human
stories and hopefully ones that we that
come from a truthful honest place so
hopefully people connect to them and and
I think that's the case with pants they
also get a gift from their father hmm
so it's curious to know is there
something meaningful that your parents
have given you when he was young he
bought this vintage Cartier watch and
when I turned 21
he had it housed and gave it to me for
my 21st birthday Wow so that is a very
special gift for me and I look forward
to one day giving it to my son or
daughter and when they turn 21 and then
also my grandparents bought me a signet
ring like we have a family tradition we
turned 18 years signet ring which is
really cool but I don't wear it often
because there was such skinny little
fingers it flies off all the time
nightmare oh yeah my watch is very
special they're very dear to me it is
very special Chris you tweeted that
grown men were crying watching this film
right I'm curious to know did you guys
cry or get emotional while watching it
or making it and if so can you tell me
about that moment both yes well Tom
can't tell you about seeing it because
he hasn't seen the movie yet because
he's waiting to see it at the premiere
because he's awesome that's
like it's pretty bad um I think for me
I'll cry hearing the pitch to this movie
it's very emotional it's very moving I
don't say that it is like a selling
point because I know that this movie
does who's gonna sell itself it's Pixar
everyone knows Pixar they know you know
Finding Nemo they know up they know Toy
Story and I think though the reason I
was so moved and why I tweeted about
grown-man tears is this is a
relationship about brothers it's a
relationship about longing to meet a
parent that you've lost and just those
themes resonate throughout and they're
very moving and it's rooted in dan
scanlon real story and I think it was
that the the dirt with the the Korean
director who won Best Director this year
he quoted Martin Scorsese and he said
sigh and I'm gonna make it this poem was
something along the lines of the more
personal you can make your story the
more creative it'll be this is
absolutely creative and it's so personal
for Dan and so because of that it's it's
incredibly moving and and grown men are
gonna shed some tears there's a really
fun though it was a really super fun
funny movie it's a great adventure movie
for sure you're gonna go on a ride I'm
sure one day Disney will make a brother
but this is this is Pixar's Sophie's
Choice is what they're saying
[Laughter]
you come to the right time
oh but not only is this story about you
know elves and manticores and Dragons
it's also very much about humans so how
do you come up with story lines or so
personal yet relatable
well we this one was kind of yeah we you
know it's loosely based on my own
experiences with losing my dad young and
and my brother and I had not remembering
him
but we do then and I think coming from a
personal place is what makes it connect
to people but then we talked to other
artists on the film and you'd be amazed
how quickly people find their own
stories in your story and so we started
to add a lot of that into the film and
make it it made the movie a lot richer
and I think it does help the movie
hopefully connect other people 100% well
I think people definitely see themselves
in this film Pixar loves sequels I think
this one is definitely deserving of the
line are you guys planning on a second
have you talked about it are you open to
it uh we we have not even talked about
it we're just excited to to get this one
out to the world because we've been
working on it for six years and so we're
excited to get this one out and then
we'll see what happens but yeah no no no
talks about it yet this cast is so
all-star how did you guys go about
casting this film and did you know who
you wanted to voice each character yeah
you know it was it was bit by bit kind
of you know cuz you kind of start out
wanting to cast the main character and
to kind of you know set the table for it
all and were thrilled that the Tom
really he connected with the film so we
pitched in the film in London and and
you know he has he has brothers and he
was just immediately kind of into it and
so yeah and then everybody else yeah
Chris after that Chris is so he's so
perfectly barley he's wild and chaotic
and playful and and confident it helps
that they knew each other you know that
that wasn't really something we thought
about at the time it was a happy totally
secondary thought but they have a
brotherly quality so it comes through
yeah it really does their chemistry is
so palpable who is this movie for well I
mean the cliche answer is that it's for
everyone
I do think it's you know it's for it's
for anyone who has a family or people
they care about which you know covers a
lot of people it's for anyone that's had
someone in their life family or not go
above and beyond to help them and
encourage and support them you know I
think it's a love letter to those folks
and yeah and I think yeah I think it'll
make everybody kind of think about that
and think about the people in their life
for just a moment
you